it is the beginning
of july 2021 we're now officially
halfway through the year so it's time
for another monthly
update video and i'm going to talk about
what went on in the month of june
quite a lot of stuff what we've got
coming up in
july a busy month as well and
if you click the show more whatever it
looks like in your interface you can see
the video description
with links and dates and all the stuff
i'm going to be referencing here
so you know check on that if you're
interested in any of these things
in particular i always like to begin by
highlighting
three big things so with no further ado
big thing number one you may have seen
the video
come out yesterday i'm starting a new
series that i'm calling
quick takes and it wasn't totally quick
but
you know quick enough i'm gonna be
talking directly
to viewers about you know things that i
think are important like for example
being intimidated by
approaching philosophical texts which
was the topic of the first one big
thing number two i'm also doing
something new with the podcasting
in my soundcloud channel and all the
other places it goes to
creating things that i'm calling
sadler's shorts where i'm taking
a passage from a key thinker and doing a
little bit of explanation
trying to keep it relatively short like
you know
under six or seven minutes tops
big thing number three so many of you
may know i brought out a
course on basics of stoic philosophy and
practice on the listenable
platform so i looked at the numbers for
that and it looks like quite a feasible
platform so i'm going to be producing
more classes on that program starting
this month so
you can check below and see a link to my
profile
tune in again and you'll see what other
courses i develop i'll of course post
them in social media
and create videos for them as well so
those are the three big things let's
talk now about
june june has been
a brutally busy month i i picked up
a lot of new clients and i also
had two online classes open
and they're in full swing one at
milwaukee area technical college the
other
at milwaukee institute of art and design
so a lot of back end work on those
i also was in two different
online events one was the recent
aristotle and the aristotelian
tradition conference where harold kavli
and i presented what we've
been working on for quite a long time is
collaborating on the notion
of proirasis in aristotle epictetus
alexander vaphredesius and simplicius
i also along with andy shaka my wife and
partner
gave a presentation at the recent
stoicon x
women conference in june as well about
stoicism
and and relationships what else you know
we continue down with the wisdom for
life
radio show we did you know the usual
events the ask me anything session
um worlds of speculative fiction we
started a new series
with going to philip jose farmer's world
of tears
series we did political theory and
practice just this last
weekend talking about fyodor
dostoyevsky's grand inquisitor chapter
from the brothers karamazov and a bunch
of
other you know online events as well one
of the things that i started
doing last month that i'm going to
continue forward is
readings
from my book reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in france
which is now 10 years old so i thought
it would be about time to return to it
and do some live readings and people
have enjoyed them quite a bit
video work did a lot of video work this
month but i didn't get everything done
that i wanted to i got four half hour
hegel video
commentaries done didn't get any book
reviews done unfortunately
but what are you gonna do right and
um i i also did a video specifically on
the stoic philosophy course with
listenable
um i i did a another one of the twitter
videos
richard dawkins kind of as we say showed
his rear
on twitter making himself look kind of
foolish criticizing kafka's
metamorphosis a lot of people had
interesting things to say so i did a
video about that
we did a caption contest video as well i
did a few
personal videos um you know the sadler
stories things and i
also did some remastering so i continued
on with the epictetus and coridian
remastering but i also took
something that was originally uploaded
in the fayetteville state university
channel because back then youtube didn't
allow you to
upload as an individual long videos so i
downloaded it remastered it and it's on
the
christian philosophy debates it's my
address that i gave during uh
national library week in 2011
so another 10 year old thing i also did
some uh
new intro to philosophy videos
specifically for my students enrolled in
intro to philosophy i thought they could
find those quite
interesting and you know they've been
getting some good traction and
and you know comments from from other
people who find them useful
uh so that's good and as i mentioned the
first of the quick
takes video i i did something
specifically
for my students but also for lifelong
learners anybody who feels
intimidated in opening up a book of
philosophy maybe they feel it's not for
them i'm giving them a pep talk
podcast work you know pretty
straightforward
we continued on with plato's symposium
there were you know 22 videos in that
series
and then we just finished up today with
the last podcast episode on wd ross's
the right and the good there's i think
10 podcast episodes
in that series as well so
you know a lot of good good content
there
and that's pretty much it for june um
you know been working out uh taking
walks
some of you may have seen my pictures
that i post
our cat was sick she still is
you know recovering um and that's
you know that's been more or less the
month
what do we have coming up in the month
of
july no conferences which is kind of
good news for me so i can get caught up
on
course building and other things right
but i do have a number of online events
that you might want to participate in
coming up on the third saturday all of
these times by the way
uh central standard time or central
daylight time whatever we're in right
now it's central time right
on the third at 12 that's noon we'll be
having
our ama that's ask me anything session
following that at two o'clock for
patreon supporters i will be having my
philosophy chat
that's a more you know more interactive
thing we use video conferencing for that
on the 10th the following saturday we'll
continue on the with the worlds of
speculative fiction series
and we will be talking about the
you know book four five and six in
philip jose farmer's
amazing world of tears series
so if you want to join in on that
there's two parts to that there's a
video premiere that happens
and then following that we do a video
conferencing session
it starts at 12 noon and the video
conferencing
probably around 1 30 p.m
on the 14th at 5 pm we have our public
hegel q a and discussion you can pop in
it's video conferencing
anybody can come in so long as they've
got an interest in hegel and german
idealism and
philosophy on the 17th you can join
me and scott tarrouli for classic metal
class
we haven't yet decided on exactly what
topic we're going to do but we're
thinking something that does have to do
with ethics and bands and the kinds of
selections
that they they engage in i'll tell you
more about that a little bit later
maybe i'll create a teaser video or
something like that
for it that's at noon as well uh the
following day
uh the 18th at 12 p.m noon
we'll have our next political mission
and that's also tbd
at this time we'll figure out exactly
what we're going to talk about
a little bit later finally at the very
end of the month
on the 29th at um six o'clock p.m
milwaukee's stoic fellowship we're going
to be
discussing cicero's four characters or
four
roles four personae very important part
of
stoic ethics everybody's welcome you
don't have to be in milwaukee because we
do it over
zoom we have a number of other things
coming up of course the wisdom for life
radio show
you can hear it a lot you can hear it on
the radio
in the in this area and you can also
hear it over the internet
at 4 00 p.m on saturdays and i'm going
to be doing some more of those
live readings from from my book there we
go
i haven't yet decided precisely when i'm
going to do those so stay tuned and i'll
be posting about those as well
video work i'm going to be doing some a
lot of core concept videos
that are specifically for my intro to
philosophy class that i'm teaching
this summer with milwaukee institute of
art and design so one of the texts that
i selected was mills on liberty
i did some videos on it in the past but
i want to do some
more on topics i didn't get to i'm also
going to be
talking about trolley problems we're
going to be reading judith jarvis's
thompson's
piece on the trolley problem which is
playing off of
um you know earlier piece but it's it's
probably one of the best ones
for undergraduates to use to approach it
so we'll be doing some discussion of
that
um i'm also going to be doing some
remastering of
and caridian videos i don't think we'll
get through the entire
set uh this month but we'll give it a
shot right
i'll do some more intro to philosophy
videos for my students
use the internet effectively to study
philosophy
not just in an academic setting but as a
lifelong learner so
i'll be doing some videos on that got
some half hour hegel videos to do
i really do want to get to some book
reviews and this month i'm hoping
also to do a review of a book that i
know a lot of people are quite excited
about
nick lands fang numina i'm going to try
to do that i'm getting
interviewed for a podcast i might do
some more personal sadler's stories
videos
or you know depending on who makes a
fool of themself
on twitter i might do another twitter
video uh
i'll definitely be doing another caption
contest because we've got
you know i put out one with me and the
bronze fawns here in milwaukee and
people are weighing in on it
uh and then you know i'll do more quick
takes videos as well and you know
i might do some other stuff i i don't
really know you know that's
kind of uh decide you know something
needs to be done i do it on my channel
that's the cool thing about about having
your own channel
um i've got a lot of other work i'll be
working on you know course
management and production and grading
and you know i've got all my
my clients that i'm working with as well
podcast stuff so
as i mentioned in the three big things
i'm
releasing some new kinds of podcast
stuff
that i call sadler shorts and
you might check those out you could find
those quite interesting
those are you know something i'm
producing
specifically not from a video the way
i've done the previous ones
but precisely just for uh
soundcloud and then everything else that
soundcloud goes to
apple podcast spotify you name it right
i'm also going to be doing some more of
the sadler's lectures
uh specifically on mills on liberty
because i need them for my my students
right
and i'll probably be working on some on
william james
pragmatism as well chapter two of that
some
some lectures i did a while back if i
get to it i'll also do some
on pierre ado uh philosophy is a way of
life
that that nice section on spiritual
practices that i did some lectures on
we'll see how all of this works out and
that is you know hopefully everything
going on this month
you know i'm going to continue working
out and doing all sorts of other
stuff in the background and that's
pretty much it so hopefully you can join
me at some of these online events
and you know i look forward to
producing this content saying what you
think about it
as i mentioned before you can click the
show more
or whatever else you need to see to get
to the video description and there'll be
links to all of these things below
that you can check out so hopefully you
have a great month hopefully i have a
great month
and that's what's going on
you